un abbraccio
[Musica]
episodio ha detto di no ma questa volta
saremo con il ruolo delle oggi aiuteremo
i trucchetti da via per giocare ma scudi
nuovo gara super divertenti più anche
voi avrete delle tavole quindi mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn e iniziamo
subito a fare il primo pensiero i nostri
dal calderone
felice rete è il giallo che e berlino
sono qui
in realtà il primo no ma iniziamo il
tour
ovviamente sono stata io sabotare il
rettore perché devo provare il mio primo
trucchetto da spia prima cosa che devo
trovare sono le hayer pozzo di celeste
forza qua nel cassetto
l'ho in mente un trucchetto da spia
infallibile rendiamo una delle pop fatto
ora aspetto che torni celeste e poi
metterò questa il pot nel suo cappuccio
ha mai salvato il reattore bravissimo
grazie ma giro di un momento stavo
pensando magari cambia colore in viola e
nel prossimo sarai celeste così
riuscirei a nasconderti meglio il viola
secondo me perché più scuro
effettivamente vi potrei nascondere al
meglio con il viola ora prima di
iniziare il conteggio e andare a
nascondervi e ci vuole un abbraccio a
braccio
un abbraccio
quantunque la nostra braccio niente
volevo solo abbracciati per augurare
buona fortuna
fate nel suo cappuccio ora sarò in grado
di localizzarlo ma prima scegliamo la
nostra arma è una prima task per voi
scrivi un commento con un emoji del
colore del tuo personaggio quando giochi
namhong come mista il verde secondo voi
che mi seguite da tanto tempo sapete che
io un po di sfortuna con il bird sheikh
prendo cellulare e localizza roll airpod
così saprà esattamente dove vasco
svizzerotto nascosto benissimo non mi
troverà mai qua dentro penso che neanche
io riuscirò a trovarvi quad è tra gli
ordini questa applicazione mi dice
seller pot è vicino o lontano dice acqua
e fuoco come il gioco acqua acqua acqua
profonda si sta avvicinando poco
poverello quindi saprò benissimo dove lo
tutto vitale è troppo divertente con
questo trucco da spia vediamo dice che
qua siamo lontano proviamo terminare un
mi dice che ci stiamo avvicinando
viviano secco no tra diminuendo il
segnale è invece da questa partita
indiani sta aumentando
guardate non c'è nessuno qua ma se
quella di lettere e giallo tu che ci fai
o trovato il giallo da quando il
tappetino di erba pinter il 1 o
violentato dice che siamo molto vicini
vedete nella barra è diventato rosso
quindi siamo un fuocherello annuncia di
strumento per queste sì da scorta 71 per
cento
aumenta la durata fuoco fuoco fuoco
fuoco sembra 90 per cento
sempre che sia proprio dietro 95 per
cento nasconde
mi chiamo
[Applauso]
bruno olivero cosa spia è usato scusa
quando ti ho abbracciato questo le bozze
o geolocalizzato le bozze con il mio
cellulare
questo è proprio un trucco della vera
spia professionista prossimo expo brawn
abbiamo cambiato cappelli la seconda
sarà lì per voi e di lasciare un mi
piace qui sotto entro tre secondi tre
tiri siamo solo noi chiedono tre ste
cose che stavolta la piccolissima
passiamo ora pescare dal calderone
questa volta pesca giallo per commodore
lido e che già allora pescare dal caffè
tutti hanno deciso di portare due ruoli
e crew mail e l'altro è eight per questa
rai
avete visto lo scarso bisogno di berlino
nel grand occhiata un pezzo di crew mail
attenzione io ho già scelto la mia arma
segreta da ninja così diamo questo come
rimasta un miglio sotto le scale per un
po rischioso come nascondiglio bene
l'arma e qui è la scelta adesso vi
mostro un trucco da spia fenomenale
questo trucco infatti permette di
sentire attraverso i muri attraverso le
porte e adesso vi faccio vedere come
guardate e di terreni per fare questo
trucchetto mi basta un palloncino e una
casa a gennaio zac precisi dettagliati
ecco qua fatto e vede commesso il
palloncino qua sopra e adesso andiamo
insieme a spiare i sogni mura i suoi di
porto ed iniziamo subito a questo modo
si sente niente troviamo su quest'altro
muro
certo qualcosa sì e lei e poi dire
troppo devo prenderla qui c'è già giallo
sia un giallo è stato preso a trovare
anche verde
ha vinto chi ha riposto reale secondo
round di nuovo gestore impostore
qualcosa terzo che esca giallo giallo si
fa sempre trovare se l'intuizione
berlino mentre mangia raccomanda ma che
è una pentola di puggioni 6 ma aggiunto
tutto è scelto verrà presa lino vediamo
cos'è uno di noi due siamo crew mail
perché per me pensi ha visto mito un
gioco da spia da utilizzare contro
merlino io ho un'idea saremo altro pezzo
di nascondere la camera di sicurezza
dentro un pupazzo prepariamo la prima
che merlino issima insospettirsi
ora dobbiamo solo scegliere un po pazzo
prendiamo questo ci fosse una seconda
della camera nel khumbu cio
dell'unicorno che genio ma niente io
volevo dire che questo unicorno molto
carino sì sì è molto carino
aspettiamoci merlino si sta
insospettendo ci sta guardando in modo
molto strano e siamo l'operazione
unicorno non devi tagliare nei
distruggere niente mica possiamo far
passare il filo d'acqua che non sono
ancora vediamo nel cellulare se si veda
mar morto si sta inquadrando la stanza
in diretta oggi la scomparsa
allora il piano è questo noi guardiamo
le camere di sicurezza e aspettiamo che
merlino lasci la stazza una volta che
lascerà la stanza entreremo e metteremo
la nostra targhetta dal rue nate nel
calderone così avremmo vinto il turno
ora con telecamere perché sa cosa sta
facendo a questo impostore sembra stia
dormendo alla grandissima
così mostra cosa sia accordo della carne
un duo nel segno trovato la camera che
sta facendo male mangiarla che succede
ha preso la camera si è accorto della
camera aprendo una camera ora non lo so
non si vede niente che succede
ruby gorno annuncia l'ho trovato la
camera dobbiamo
scusate ma ti guardo se il giorno
trovato la camera stava cercando di
sgranocchiare tutta l'erba e pensavamo
di riuscire a berlino via teatro berlino
ma è troppo intelligente e capisce
questo e luciano vediamo se vinceranno
come te li motoria o se vinceranno i
primi mesi questa volta andiamo a
pescare ultim'ora torano pescara i
nostri ruoli bono giocatore impostore
per l'ultimo sarò io il pastore ma
questo vuol dire che io a meri diciamo
più mail si è un po stanco sta già
dormendo brutto berlino sei pronto a
fare il kuwait bene voi iniziate a
pensare al vostro nascondiglio ho in
mente un trucco da spia molto molto
interessante non so se funzionerà spero
di devo trovare una scusa per prendere
le impronte digitale di vitale prima di
iniziare con il quarto round dobbiamo
rifare le targhette e targhette sì
perché siccome berlino ha distrutto una
delle targhette devo rifare gli
identikit del crew mail e per fare gli
identikit del crew metz devo prendere la
tua impronta digitale
ok va bene io nel frattempo invece ho
messo il vaso il vaso in testa il vaso
con fiori in testa li vado a mettere un
po al sole che stai facendo fossero
girasoli velo che le piante devono
prendere un po di sole per crescere di
testa mia
meno prendono un po di sole quindi posso
versarsi un po d'acqua in testa no in
testa non mi serve il tubo alice per
prendere le tue impronte digitali non me
lo vorrai mica tagliare il pollo
giovanna queste per tagliare lo scotch e
poi rossetto per prendere le impronte
digitale e kraft e ora tigers molto bene
ho tutto quello che vi serve a modo loro
reddito non voglio rimanere col rossetto
sul pollice e vai pure vai questa
impronta digitale mi servirà per
sbloccare il cellulare di vitale e
perché mi serve sbloccarlo
ho un piano devo dire che molto che in
questo colore spiegarmi eccolo qua spero
che funzioni
vediamo devo portare l'improntitudine
non appiccicosa qua
vediamo
ma per il quale se di vitale così grande
rispetto al pulsante non funziona iv
flotta di titta ruffo quello che volevo
fare sbloccare il telefono e mettere la
sveglia 5 o 10 minuti
così una volta che sono una sveglia io
saprò dove è vitale funziona vediamo se
riesco mettere la sveglia anche senza
sbloccare e il sì li metti il timer
cinque minuti è vitale mai finito di
lavarsi le mani
speriamo ci vitale mila morti le mani
dai vite nascondersi e dimenticato c'è
una ricche di bari vai vai vai ashton è
di nuovo non è dei 35 minuti sono era la
sveglia io saprò benissimo dov'è
nascosto vitale anche se l'imprenditore
non ha funzionato il piano funzionato
scegliamo subito l'arma se il gioco
resta
non mi resta che aspettare copre qualche
minuto e una volta che solo la sventare
verso il suono della sveglia provato a
nascondermi adesso pure in giardino
potrebbe essere una buona idea qui nel
reattore non lo so l'altra volta ho
provato a nascondermi sotto il tavolino
del reattore era troppo piccolo
se mi è venuta un'idea beh è giallo l'ho
già trovato perché sta dormendo
guardate giallo sta berlino sta
sorridendo con i denti per lei che
carino merlino vede sorride che verso il
riso che vedenti il sasso ma dopo
sentite anche merlino se n'è accorto
arma ricaricata non ci resta che andare
a prendere vitale il cellulare ma non
c'è vitale un altro 11
andiamo subito proteggere il cantone non
deve poter mettere la targhetta m devo
ben tre radar che tocco targhetta perché
targhetta calderone
come hai fatto capire il mio piano
perché mi è sembrato strano che mi davi
così all'improvviso il mio cellulare che
io ho pensato chissà che cosa avrà fatto
magari avrò fatto uno scherzetto come
prima con gli spot quindi ho detto va
bene ok forse è meglio non fidarsi
sparando ultimata per voi scrivete nei
commenti qual è stato il trucchetto da
stia che vi è piaciuto più di tutti
e se non avete visto l'altro video in
cui giochiamo a nascondino among us
cliccate qua per andare a vederlo se
volete vedere supermario in una vita
reale clicca qua se vuoi vedere altre
nostre sale
clicca qua per inoltre oggi video clicca
qui
ciao